what is going on everybody and welcome
to a video where I'm going to be
checking out the Pluto X drone which is
kind of a DIY tinkering type of drone
that you can find on good ol IndieGoGo
so the people here hit me up wanted me
to check it out I see a DIY kind of
tinkering programmable drone I say yes
give it to me so this is their their
page
I think the let's see the campaign so is
nine days left the drone itself I'm
pretty sure if you purchase it in the
next nine days no idea when this video
is going to be coming out hopefully
somewhere in that window of nine days
but 169 so already pretty hard to go
wrong at 169 for a programmable drone I
believe the size is about the size of
your hand or so it's kind of hard to
tell somewhere in here somebody had one
so like that one looks like it's about
the size of a hand and then somewhere
down here I saw another photo anyways
basically you can program it's got like
a API based SDK I'm pretty sure from the
things that I've seen that would be in
C++ which I do not know but they say you
don't need to know it so but surely I'll
be alright
and then everything basically is
open-source it comes with a bunch of
sensors and breakout board but you've
got things like distance sensors and
there's even a camera and stuff so
pretty darn cool so anyways you guys can
read the IndieGoGo page I'll put a link
in the description I want to play with
this thing so I'm first I'm going to
open the box I haven't actually opened
it unfortunately it came so it came all
the way from India but it won't like
someone a little interest anyways
beautiful box careful to not show all
the address information
[Applause]
Wow this is wait crazily wrapped first
rule of filming oh my gosh this is
really this is some creek it's like oh
it's like I've never seen packing
material like this I don't know if you
can tell it's like woven on the inside I
guess that stops it from ripping oh the
hardest unboxing and I get a lot of
stuff from Amazon I'm pretty good at
opening boxes okay of the box so
beautiful oh oh interesting
I don't think I should show this but it
has a username and password on the lid
of this box I should Mike should
probably keep that around I've got a
nice sticker and the drone is already
put together whoa dude this thing looks
awesome this is very very light this is
cool okay and then we've got some extra
propellers they do have a these little
like propeller guards and generally
you're gonna lose propellers when it
hits like a wall or something so
hopefully these little propeller guards
will solve for that and hopefully they
won't break the other killer four
propellers I found as if the propeller
is cheap enough under enough torque of a
motor it will just the propeller just
flies off like it just breaks now these
are pretty small propellers and they're
probably pretty small motors so maybe we
won't have to worry about that but
unlike some of these drones here
the motors are very strong and you have
to be very careful you can't just buy
any propeller
anyway we've got extra propellers I'm
assuming there should be like two types
of propeller these are like B propellers
and these are your a propellers so if
you get it don't forget that there's two
different types of propellers that I
screwed me up when I was first getting
into drones and building them what do we
get here what do we got here but more
importantly would be like some sort of
informational packet of what's included
here like like a parts list would be
really useful right about now I think
they have like a getting started thing
they've emailed me I should probably go
read that I have no idea what this is
but it looks like a board of some kind
I'm gonna dude my knife these look like
wheels I'm it could be totally wrong but
I'm pretty sure these are wheels for
converting it to a car like a little
rover type thing oh and a camera that'll
be fun
so this whole thing I'm pretty sure is
Wi-Fi based I could be wrong I know it
at least has Wi-Fi cool I can't wait to
see how good the camera works so the
camera I'll have to go back and see I'm
not sure what differentiates the
tinkerer kit oh this is the earlybird
tinkerer kicks I know you get extra
stuff with the tinkerer kit but a camera
on a drone that you can program is
open-source but also comes
out-of-the-box ready to fly for 169
dollars now I don't know what shipping
is to the United States or to like
Europe or something like that so maybe
the shipping will kill you but dude okay
these look like extra motors more
stickers and a rookie pilot badge who's
gonna wear the rookie pilot badge okay
that should be everything now I'm gonna
see if I can find some instructions of
any kind also I'm gonna suspect since it
was a battery and it was shipped it's
probably discharged almost all the way
so it probably needs to be charged so
now comes the anti-climactic
most likely I have to charge this but
hey and they didn't give us a micro USB
charger what am I supposed to have these
things lying around Jays okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
all right now we're gonna check out the
programmable aspect to the Pluto X drone
because that's what really is gonna make
or break this as a $170 drone so how
easy can we actually get in and start
playing with the drone so this is the
the blue X API documentation is about 30
page PDF it contains just a huge amount
of functions for us at least from my
glancing through here probably like
every function you could want is already
written for you so you don't really need
to do a lot of like the lower level
types of stuff here so really very
quickly you should be able to start
playing with the drone and testing
things and just kind of poking around
and also because there's LEDs on the
drone itself you can start kind of
playing with various logic pretty
quickly without actually requiring the
drone to be in flight which is a nice
way for you to like slowly ease into it
so anyways this is the documentation you
guys can read that on your own what I
want to show you guys is writing your
own code we're just gonna write
something super super simple we're gonna
talk about debugging and the graphing
and stuff like that and just kind of see
like flashing to the drone how easy is
the entire workflow process basically so
let's get started so the first thing
that we're gonna do is one thing you
could do to by the way is check out if
you go to Girona Aviation comm then go
to learn they've got some information
here for you and then I found this stuff
by scrolling down and go into their
github which actually pointed to v3 are
Pluto but you can also on the same
github find the Pluto X sample codes and
they've got all kinds of stuff here so
if you just want to get some ideas about
how you can work with certain things
it's always fun just to check out sample
code but we're actually not going to be
using that so good day the thing I am
going to use is well when you go there
you can get there Cygnus so if you go to
that link I was just showing you guys
they talked about downloading the Cygnus
IDE you also probably should have gotten
that in some sort of welcome document
that says hey here download this thing
so I'm gonna go ahead and run the AI
and show you guys working with all this
stuff so I'll go with the default
workspace that is fine all right so this
is what you're greeted with go ahead go
file new we're gonna go a Pluto X
project and we're gonna call this
testing around or something like that's
great and what you get is just kind of a
basic skeleton of code so what do you
want to do when the you know Pluto X
basically turns on I'm pretty sure this
is when developer mode is activated and
so like this will just run one time so
anything you want to set up whenever
that gets activated then you've got the
Pluto pilot this is the thing that just
happens in an infinite loop until where
we are done with script basically and
then here's the very end so here if I
say you're tinkering with LEDs or
obviously if you're running motors on
pilot finish you probably want to make
sure the motors are stopped and the LEDs
are back to wherever they started and
all of that so what we're gonna do is
we're going to come up to the
tippity-top here we're gonna make two
more imports so we're gonna bring in two
more employers I guess I'll call them
include sorry Python programmer here
we're gonna bring in the print API in
the control so we'll bring in print dot
H and then we're gonna bring in control
dot H so print allows us both to print
to this little monitor area so this
would just be any static values you just
want to print out for debugging purposes
and also print contains the graphing so
you can actually graph things on the red
graph the green graph or the blue graph
so if you want to like monitor trends or
changes over time sometimes I can be
hard if you're just looking at like
static you know print statements so here
what we can see is just how things are
changing over time so it can be kind of
useful there so the next thing that
we're gonna do is on the init we don't
really care pilot start we don't really
care we're gonna go straight for the
loop so let's just write something
really really simple all its gonna do is
we can check to see if the drone is okay
to actually arm and the reason why we
would want to do that is like is the
drone actually okay to take off so if
the drone is relatively stable then we
should say yeah it's
by safe to armed if the drone is upside
down no it would be unwise of us to
armed the drone and take off so we can
use this boolean check here so one thing
we could say is we could just do print
dot and then the method to actually
print to that like monitor is just
monitor and then you monitor your you
know your character and then basically
it's any string tags so you could say
something like this you could say we'll
do a new line and then safe and then we
could ask basically just control and
then it's is okay or something like that
let's find it is art is okay to arm and
that's just a simple boolean question
now I also want to graph it and I
believe it would be a little more
efficient for us to define probably it
to save it to a variable I can't really
I don't really know because this is
already a boolean someone can tell me
below also let's not forget our
semicolons we need them so the other
thing that we're going to do is print
and this time we're gonna go with the
red graph and then here we just it's a
value so again control is okay to arm
just do this and then precision for most
sensors you'd probably go with like a
three or four or something but we'll
just we'll go with four again semicolon
and yeah so one thing I don't know is if
it would be it depends on what this
function is actually doing but you might
have you might rather do something like
bool okay arm equals control is okay to
arm like this
like I said actually don't know which
one would be more efficient if that's
like a waste there or not but you can do
something like that too anyways whatever
you have got your code you're happy
you're feeling good you're gonna next
thing you want to do is build it this
checks to make sure you haven't screwed
up you didn't forget your semicolons or
anything you want to make sure you do
this before you flash to your drone
because if you've got an air in here you
might not have a good day so so anyways
our build was successful we're happy so
the next thing that we want to do is if
you're connected to your your pluto on
your phone now if you're connected to
the Wi-Fi it's totally fine but on the
phones app if you're connected to the
Pluto drone disconnect so
make sure your disconnected the other
thing is mine isn't even on so I'm gonna
go ahead and turn it on make sure your
drones on and now on your main PC you'll
want to connect to your drones Wi-Fi so
I am going to do that now okay and then
once you're connected to the drones
Wi-Fi and you are disconnected to the
drone via your phone's app you are ready
to connect the IDE to the drone oh also
if you have the camera connected to your
drone and you're using like the cameras
a little Wi-Fi thing you got a
disconnect the camera first for whatever
reason it just doesn't work because it's
a separate Wi-Fi also that Wi-Fi is
totally insecure
so anyway it just doesn't work at least
for me so anyways make sure the camera
also is not connected to the drum okay
once all those things are done connect
to the drone so once this if this turns
and stays read it means good we're
connected so the next thing we have is
if we've already built and we're
confident the next thing we can do is
flash it to the drone again before you
flash make sure you are not connected
via your phone's app you just won't be
able to flash so we're gonna do a normal
flash at two choices full flash or
normal flash the full flash will erase
like things like the calibration and all
that and I don't really want to have to
recalibrate every time so normal flash
so we will wait on that should be pretty
quick all right and we got some flashy
flashes from the LEDs telling us that it
looks like it probably worked all right
so after the flash it seems the IDE
disconnects so go ahead and reconnect it
again and then now what we want to do is
go to our phone app make sure your phone
is connected to the Pluto X Wi-Fi and
hit connect so I need to connect to the
Wi-Fi all right and once you've
connected to the Pluto the default is
still going to be not running your code
so like if we go to Pluto monitor right
now nothing's really happening nothing's
happening on the graphs this is because
we're not in developer mode so you
there's two ways to do it there's like a
button that's like closing tags the
lower-left on your phone app you can
either poke that or you can hit volume
up on your phone and that will enable
developer mode and
enough we can see it's already starting
to spam out safe sections and one means
yes it is safe we can also check out the
graphs it's just steady one here
now if I pick up the drone though and I
turn it over we can see no it goes to
zero now because it's not safe and if we
go to the monitor now it should be
spamming zeros and so we can keep like
flipping it back so safe not safe safe
not safe okay so pretty cool that's how
you can start to like monitor things
with your amazing beautiful C++ code so
anyway that's it for now pretty darn
simple to like set everything up I'm
really impressed I definitely think it's
worth 170 so yeah definitely go check
them out if you're interested in like
programming this stuff also I'm like
just curious about learning C++ and I
figure this is a pretty darn good way to
do so so anyway that's it for now
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below again the
IndieGoGo link is in the description if
you're interested otherwise I will see
you guys in another video